[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris mannix sports illustrated nba
senior rider joining us
from phoenix he uh was in attendance for
last night's game between the clippers
and the suns what's your big takeaway
from last night there chris
you know just the resiliency of the
clippers
i mean we've seen it throughout these
playoffs going down
2-0 in both the first and second round
but
you know this come back and and win in
this game
was maybe even more impressive to me i
mean they learned
about the injury and well the extent of
the injury to zubach uh
at the morning shoot around and to
already down
you know serge ibaka kawhi leonard and
now being down
your best big man going up against a big
physical team with a guy like deandre
ayton
uh to still be able to not only rally
and win but they came out
fast dan i mean they were up 20 to five
uh early in this game they had multiple
opportunities
in the second half to fold you know
the clippers have this this this this
history
of not showing up in big moments that
history regardless of what happens in
this series
i think has been uh you know largely
erased because of the performance of
this team
but you try to handicap this series i
wasn't surprised said i wouldn't be
surprised if the clippers won last night
because
why not now they go back home where
you would expect the clippers to win so
what do you expect here in game six uh
you know i have i have no idea
you know there's an art there's an
argument to be made that
you know this was kind of the clippers
shooting their shot here this was
everything they had left in the tank
paul george look at the minutes paul
george has played
in this post i think it's like 735 which
is like 130 more
than anybody else uh in these playoffs i
mean
sitting in the the interview room after
the game i mean he looked exhausted
marcus morris who has battled a knee
injury
of his own had to go 41 minutes largely
against deandre ayton
he looked exhausted i mean there's only
so many
you know proverbial bullets they have
left in the chamber and
you know going home i'm sure they'll get
a bounce off that home crowd and
you know one thing these these clippers
players said last night to a man
was that you know they knew they were
down 3-1
but you know they looked at it like a
couple of breaks here or there the
valley oop you know better offense in
game four they could have been up
3-1 in this series they've got a little
bit of confidence but
at some point all these injuries start
to take their toll and if zubach
can't go uh in this game six i just have
a hard time seeing ayton struggle
as much as he did and the sons uh play
as poorly defensively as they did
what is kawhi leonard's status i
wouldn't expect to see him
uh in these playoffs no matter if it
goes game seven
i i don't believe it there's i have not
heard
any indications and kawhi as we all know
plays everything kind of close to chess
but
you know you get kind of you talk to
clippers personnel
um you know whether it's on site or you
know you know via text message you just
don't don't get you don't get positive
indications that kawhi
is coming back i don't know the full
extent of that injury
if it is something that may require
surgery down the line but
there are no indications yet that that
kawhi is
you know and a return is imminent but is
this an injury that is going to stay
with him or
a condition that is going to stay with
him the rest of his career
well it's hard to say with this injury
specifically now he has had that knee
problem
that has need to be load managed since
his days at san antonio
i would say that particular version of
the injury
is going to be with him for his entire
career i mean kawhi i forget how old he
is right around 30
at this point but so i don't expect that
to change anytime soon so over the
course of an 82 game season
we're going to see kawhi at most play 60
65 games
for the rest of his career this injury
felt a little bit different this was one
of those
yeah kind of injuries in the moment that
we may
we may find out later that it was an acl
injury that requires some type of
surgery but
there's the the day of kawhi leonard dan
playing 80 games in a season those days
are longs it's over
gosh i don't remember those days when's
when's the last time he was ever close
to that
2012 maybe 2013. like we got to go back
to the
early san antonio days uh before you
know that injury happened that cost him
almost a full season that last full
season uh with the spurs so look it's
not the end of the world
i mean toronto won a championship with
kawhi you know being low managed
uh throughout i think the clippers you
know you could argue if
kawhi leonard was healthy uh you know
they'd be the favorites to win the
championship this year there's
there's a pathway for them to win or any
team that has kawhi leonard to win
with him being load managed is just kind
of a fact of life for him going forward
have we been unfair we the media been
unfair to paul george
in our expectation level
i don't know um i think social media
probably has but social media is unfair
to everybody social media mostly boxing
fans hate me
like so like i mean it's like it doesn't
it is kind of what it is
when it comes to critiques now i'm sure
if paul paul
paul george could hop in the time
machine
he would go back and not say what he
said in that clip you played like he
would not
call himself playoff p like that has
kind of stuck to him like white on rice
there and
it ratcheted up the level of expectation
if you call yourself playoff p
and then you subsequently have
back-to-back
uh early playoff exits in oklahoma city
you blow a 3-1 lead with the clippers
that is going to be something you are
tagged with for the rest of his career
but
when you're a superstar and you don't
win championships
i mean lebron james gets criticized
still he's won multiple championships
that just kind of comes uh with the
territory when it comes to
being a player of that status yeah pg-13
we were okay with
like that was a nice cute nickname you
know but
playoff p you know has anybody like as
has anybody that's given themselves a
nickname
ever felt good about it afterwards i i'm
i'm struggling thinking of the top of my
head who else has given themselves
nicknames but usually like shaq gave
paul pierce the truth
and that stuck and that worked well for
paul pierce
over his career if somebody gives you a
nickname
it's great because even if it doesn't uh
even if you don't live up to it you
didn't give it to yourself like it
wasn't you that's called yourself that
when you call yourself playoff bee uh
you you put a target on your back if you
don't play like someone
that lives up to those expectations well
dion called himself prime time
like lived up to lived up to it yeah
like if you you can call yourself prime
time you know what
you call yourself the greatest of all
time like and
and certainly is in the discussion for
for that as
or a favorite to be called that i mean
if if somebody calls
himself mvp if he gets what he did and
he won multiple mvps
you lived up to it but if you're playoff
p and you and you struggle look
i do think he's this is the best post
season he's had since
his indiana days you know maybe better
because of the he's put in a position
without a danny granger or danny of
david west
that are around him i mean like he was
shooting 35
going into that game five and you look
at the first half and he was pretty
passive and you could see kind of the
critics start to warm up
and i think even i wasn't listening to
it but i had seen tweets about the
broadcast were criticizing
uh paul george for that first half and
then to come out in the third quarter
just blow the doors off 20 points they
get three three pointers
uh in that period i mean that was that
was a playoff p
level performance for paul george
talking to chris mannix the
sports illustrated nba senior writer why
do boxing fans hate you
uh they think my score cards suck
i do that for design and uh boxing's
polarizing though everybody thinks they
they know exactly what they're talking
about it's it's probably one of the
worst sports for that
okay i've just i just it's there yeah
watch a big
fight watch a big fight on social media
it's it's interesting you know i don't
do social media
that's true paulie does though so he'll
get he can text you by the way social
media
uh yesterday was scottie pippen uh were
you monitoring
social media i was i saw the i saw
mclovin's tweets first and foremost then
i saw the clip i mean i'll be the
umpteenth person to tell you tremendous
interview
uh with scotty i mean i thought you did
everything you could to get to the root
of the racism charge which is the big
one
that's out there i didn't think he had a
single answer
that made any sense i had people texting
me
afterwards nba people that were just
and i'm kind of paraphrasing here but
like does scotty need some help you know
after this you know what
what what's going through his mind right
now that he would sit there
and make a racism charge i mean look
he's been
upset about the tony cucoch play for
decades now like that's
that's never going to change despite the
fact amazingly despite the fact that
kudos made the shot like he hit the shot
and and helped the bulls advance he's
scottie's still
upset about it but there's no evidence
that phil jackson is a racist in any
way shape or form players that have
played for him
have never charged him with that before
it's that's an ugly thing to say
unless you have specific examples to
back it up and
you know i watched the interview a
couple of times it
he doesn't seem to have one single
example to back it up i mean
there's a lot of weird things like
michael jordan you know controlling the
cameras
like now we're getting into tinfoil hat
conspiracy where he's
you know he's telling steve curry he's
going to pass him the ball because the
camera that he controls
is watching and he's thinking about his
documentary 20 years later there's just
a lot of
of dot connecting that scotty was doing
in that moment that didn't make a lot of
sense
um the damian lillard situation in
portland
i i can you clear like what is the
situation because i'm not sure if he
wants out
if is this passive aggressive is there
something going on
with what his future is going to be in
portland well chauncey phillips gets
introduced
as the next head coach today and my
understanding is
they're going to all try to get into a
room and figure out
if this is salvageable with damien
lillard
i grow more and more skeptical by the
day dan
that it is you know i said this on my
podcast this morning but like
damian lillard is like the guy breaking
up with the girlfriend for the first
time
like he he he wants to break up with her
but he doesn't know how to so he's going
about it in kind of a ham-handed type of
way
and that's what dame's been doing and
it's not just the last couple of days
you go back to the immediate aftermath
of the loss to the nuggets and he had
this
cryptic tweet that was a cryptic
instagram post that was out there about
how many times do i have to keep doing
this with the
the same result he then somewhat
bizarrely
goes out there and throws his support
behind jason kidd
of all people to be the head coach of
the trailblazers and
and there have been more obviously
social media posts in the last couple of
days
as well look i don't i don't think this
is about the coach
i don't think it's about blazers fans
criticizing him
for his involvement in the coaching
search
i think plain and simple damien lillard
at 31 years old
is looking at the trailblazer's roster
and saying i can't win
and i i can't argue with him with that i
mean they got beat
by a denver nuggets team without its
second best player
that subsequently went out and got
absolutely smoked by the phoenix suns
in four games that loss has not aged
well for the trailblazers so
i think what it comes down to for
lillard as loyal as he's been to
portland
is that he wants to win as he in the
final prime years
of his career and this is kind of his
sort of somewhat clumsy way
of going out and forcing that the irony
of all this dan is that i think
a damien lillard trade is the best thing
for both sides
lillard can find his way to a new
situation give himself a chance to win
and portland which has really no chance
to win at the highest level
uh with damien little the next couple of
years can recoup
one of if not the biggest trade hall in
recent nba history i mean lillard has
that type of value
on the open market so this is kind of a
it's an awkward
situation right now but in the next few
weeks even maybe months
uh if damian lillard is traded that
could wind up being the best thing for
both sides
okay but the most likely destination and
do not say the new york knicks
no i mean and by the way please lakers
fans stop like sending your trade
machine things out that include
like contavious caldwell pope as the
centerpiece of a deal like that
unless you're dealing anthony davis
you're probably not getting
damien lillard two things to remember uh
with davis you're gonna or with uh with
lillard you're gonna work with him on a
trade you're not just gonna dump him
like on oklahoma city or something like
that where he can play
the final few years of his contract out
you're gonna work with him on where
he wants to go and you're gonna have to
find a situation where he can win that
means going to a team with at least
one second star uh that's on it then you
start to look
at the return you get like you're not
dealing
damien lillard for bradley beale because
bradley beal while being 28 years old
and still a great player
has one year left in his contract that
is not going to stay in portland beyond
one season so you're looking for kind of
what say oklahoma city got where they
got a blue chip young player
in shae gilders alexander and a hall of
draft picks
using those as the the early parameters
i would say there are two teams right
off the bat that stand out one is
philadelphia
because ben simmons is still out there
and the sixers still have
their draft capital over the next few
years simmons has signed
through 2025 and as flawed as he is he's
still
a perennial all-star at 24 years old who
if he ever fixes a shot has the
potential to be great
the other it's boston we're i can't
believe we're doing this once again
where the celtics are in the mix for
another superstar
but here we are boston has jaylen brown
he's 24 years old
he's an all-star for the first time he
gets better every single year you can
build a trade package
around jalen brown a lot of the young
players they have in boston
and their cache of draft picks over the
year years as well it's
like we're very early in this process
and because lilith is signed through
2025
you're probably gonna have teams try to
sneak in and find a deal that works but
when this started to pick up those were
the first two teams
that i thought of that are also by the
way in the eastern conference
we don't have to deal with damie lillard
for more than two times a season
and never have to deal with him in the
playoffs thank you chris we appreciate
your time as always bud
you got it dan that's chris manning
sports illustrated nba senior writer